this is just a quick message for some of
our more technologically minded viewers
about our new periodic table of QR codes
for those of you who aren't familiar
with them QR codes are these little
things which you can scan with things
like your smartphone what our table will
do is take you to our YouTube video
about each and every element now I've
put a link to a nice big high-resolution
version of the poster underneath this
video so if it looks like your sort of
thing feel free to print one out and put
it up somewhere do whatever you like
with it
we hope it comes in useful now details
about all these extra things we do can
usually be found on our Twitter page or
Facebook because we don't like to make
too many videos about them but for now I
think I'll leave you with some nice
pretty pictures of the professor having
a bit of a Brian Cox moment on the beach
in Brazil